[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
make way for the great analysts from the
mothership jeff van gundy former head
coach he was on the call celtics nets
games one in three and joins us now
what's the big difference in the celtics
and nets and why the celtics are up in a
commanding fashion
well i thought actually brooklyn played
an outstanding first two games uh on the
road they gave themselves chances to win
in both games they shot the ball better
than 50 percent in both games uh
against a great celtics defense so i
really liked the way they played the
first two games it was game three it was
the turnovers combined with
uh durant uh obviously not playing
or irving playing particularly well and
the other guys the complimentary players
around them other than bruce brown
didn't have good nights either so it was
a bad night all all the way around
and one they could ill afford
would you sign up kyrie for a long-term
contract if you're the nets
well it's tough choices now you know
because
right now their depth has been
compromised uh joe harris has been out
most of the year
so very uh
good for them from a shooting standpoint
good rebounder and he's got stability to
him and then you know ben simmons if
you're going to say you're going to
trade harden
and in this one year what you're going
to get back for arden
is seth curry who's hobbled and andre
drummond
that's a lose from a talent standpoint
too so i think you have to look at your
roster in totality
i know this because guys don't play as
much now
either minutes in the game or over
the course of the season
you have to have quality depth and
that's what right now the celtics have
built they built a strong
uh eight nine man rotation and right now
the the nets don't have
um
enough depth due to injury uh to be able
to
put it together and make a championship
run
would you sign kyrie long term
i'd have to look at all those factors
again i mean i
obviously
he's had durability issues for many
different reasons and my team has had
durability issues you know the talent is
obviously
uh
a unique offensive talent the handle and
all that shot making he hasn't played
very well uh in the last couple games
here after a great second half in game
one
uh uh just in general for getting kyrie
for the second
i think you always have to ask yourself
and i don't know what he'd get let's say
you make 40 million are you better
getting 140 million dollar player
or are you better getting
you know
not as good as the 40 million but having
two
really good 20 million dollar players i
i think you have to think about how you
want to surround simmons and durant
because those two are there and
you know you're gonna have to build
around those two let's go back a week or
so ago it felt like the nets
you know they're saying hey
ben's you know
he's been uh pain-free he's been working
out like why why are they setting him up
to be the fall guy from the standpoint
of oh wait he's not playing again
why why not just say we believe he's out
we're not expecting him to play in this
series instead of hey this could maybe
tonight like i i just don't understand
the philosophy unless they're trying to
kind of push him into come on let's go
let's play let's let's suck it up here
well dan i think at least what i've read
those are the sources saying that he's
you know on track to play in game four
when we've talked to steve nash prior to
the games that we've done he's always
said
you know i think it's too early to say
and so the reports
that were coming out of whatever camp
never matched up with what steve nash
was saying to us which was hold on he
hasn't even practiced yet and
and again
i have no idea what's going on people
who
i think it's hard to make these
hard and fast pronouncements that
he's either
letting his team down
or he's injured like none of us really
know if he's truly injured if it's a
mental health situation
or he could play he's just not
comfortable to play and so
um
i find it a really odd situation
and i certainly
uh am going to remain judgment free on
him and and what he stands for
yeah it just feels like and all steve
nash has to say is look he's not playing
that's it and that if he does come back
then we would have said oh wow okay you
know hey he's progressing farther along
like zion williamson
why is zion not playing
i mean he
can can he play 15 minutes 10 minutes 12
minutes
why why why would you not put him back
in or why is he not being put back in
well that's an interesting uh question
right there if he's
i think right now phoenix i mean i think
new orleans is going to win that series
once booker went out
and let's say he can't come back i think
they have even though they were 10 games
under 500 during the regular season
and phoenix was 64 and 18. i think
offensive talent wise
new orleans has the better team
with the addition of mccullum and
valentinus uh in the offseason but if
you throw in zion
uh for 15 minutes a game off the bench
i mean
then i think they become the prohibitive
favorite over these last three games so
i've got to believe that
you know
williamson just isn't
healthy enough to play because why
wouldn't you want to play if you were
healthy enough in the playoffs
but i also look back to michael jordan's
second year in the league he breaks his
foot
if we fast forward to now
michael jordan doesn't play in the
playoffs probably
i mean and really that was his coming
out party when he faced the celtics in
the garden and had that dominating
series and they lost but now it's about
caution load management all of that so
i i'm just curiou and it's not hey the
guys in my day era were tougher it's
just the philosophy i think is different
than it used to be
oh it's absolutely different but it's
not just different in the playoffs dan
you know that it's it's different
uh
in in how you
work in the summer sometimes i think
we take more pride in how we work out in
the summer than how we play in the
winter
um i always hear about guys having great
summers
i used to make we used to make light of
one guy when in uh back in the
late 90s early 2000s that we competed
against all they ever would say about
him was what a great summer we
this guy had you always say well how
about having a great april and day
you know i i just think
there's a lot different uh caution
is uh
is a word that you know
is
you know very in vogue and i think the
one thing
that used to be asked
um was
well if this was a playoff game
could he go yeah that that's out now too
like it's just different it's not
different bad or good
the league looks at playing through
things much differently
than
15 20 years ago that may be good or that
may be bad it depends on your
perspective talking to jeff van gundy
the analyst for espn and abc i brought
this up with uh commissioner silver a
couple of weeks ago where i said how
about you just say you got to play in a
certain number of games or certain
number of minutes to qualify for first
team second team third team all-nba all
your postseason awards you have to check
in at a certain level
therefore you know you're going to get
those players because of all the bonuses
that are attached to first second third
team or winning the mvp or defensive
player of the year all of those things
what do you think of that idea
love the idea
unfortunately because like you just said
bonuses are tied to it all you'd have to
work that out with the players
association and they're never gonna give
on that um
uh but i do think going forward in the
next collective bargaining
you have to
i know it sounds strange because you
don't give incentives
in other professions to show up at work
like hey today if you show up at work
we're going to give you
you know the chance to be
all first-team fire department but in
this situation the way the trends are
heading and i think in a negative way as
far as for fans they really don't know
oftentimes going to a game buying
tickets for a game tuning into a game
who's gonna play so
i think to give
extra incentive to either games played
minutes played for all the awards i
think is an outstanding idea
that i think the commissioner should
think very uh
long about trying to include in the next
collective bargaining agreement i think
you should be able to buy star insurance
so you play an overage on your ticket
and let's say you're
showing up to see steph curry and he
doesn't play then you get your money
back or luca
you're showing up to see luca and you
know you've got that in that star
insurance
what do you think
i like it i i think it's also
unfortunate that we're having that
conversation
you know but i i
listen i do think we have to protect the
customer and the consumer
um
right now we're on this high that you
know
um people are watching they're excited
about nba basketball
but
we can never take for granted the fans
and that they drive
the freight and i don't think adam
silver takes him for granted i hope we
as
uh teams and as a league don't take him
for granted because
once you're not giving them the product
they
think is warranted for the price you
know obviously they're gonna they're
gonna spend their money elsewhere so i
think we have to have i don't know if
it's insurance
and i think dan i don't know about you
but
i think fans understand the difference
between legit injury
and just taking a night off
um
when
they choose to take a night off yeah but
we can't ask that question jeff we're
not allowed to ask ben simmons hey why
aren't you playing
like
you're not unfortunately
because now even
and it used to hey listen the media is a
lot different too dan
um
you used to be held account
after every game you didn't get a choice
you know they uh the reporters were
allowed into the locker room and you
could run away but it was it was harder
back back then to run away now with the
zooms teams don't make people available
they don't have to answer for
either their play oftentimes
uh
and that's why i admire the players that
win or loss
good game or bad game
they stand before the media and they're
not just there when they're giving them
praise they're there when they're taken
on hard questions and i that's why i
admired what durant did it had to be
hard you know after game three uh to be
disappointed in the result in your own
play but to stand there and take it
that's what part of your pay is for your
responsibility is for
um but now it's harder and frankly
a lot of the questions are more soft
polish because they are relying on
players and the player's agents for
leaks and sources off the record so
a lot has changed in the climate of how
the game is covered too
is james harden getting old right before
our very eyes
well i think he certainly hasn't played
to the mvp level that we're accustomed
to uh and that was at in in brooklyn and
in philly but i would not underestimate
his greatness
um
i think
i always thought the dynamic between he
and embiid was going to be a challenge
because
hardin has a style that's very unique in
how he dominates the ball
and
embiid when
they play through him whether it's in
the high post the elbow or the low post
is absolutely dominant
so
it's it's a hard dance to master
actually i think they played together
uh exceptionally well i i think
they fit together better than i thought
i just don't think harden has been as
efficient from a shooting standpoint as
they need him to be if they're going to
win it all
i'll leave you with this bigger
disappointment this season the lakers or
the nets
well i think it all is where you're you
start with your expectations i i never
thought the lakers were good
like i didn't understand the hype for
their team
um
you know they were there they have an
often injured team
they
took away
and stripped down all depth and i think
depth is incredibly important in today's
nba because of games missed and people
don't play big minutes
so
my expectations for the lakers
i can't say i didn't think they'd make
the play in i thought they would be you
know an
eight nine ten type of team
um
but i'm not disappointed i thought their
roster um
was not very good the nets on the other
hand i thought going into the year
before you knew about
uh irving's uh vaccination status and
the inability to play hardens i didn't
know he was going to be discontent
and and all of that being said
january i think it was 23rd the nets
were in first place
in the eastern conference at 29 and 16.
and then durant's injury
wiped them out so you you took you know
irving's vaccination status hardens
discontent which led to simmons not
being able to play joe harris being out
all year then
rant they just got hit with a tidal wave
of roster issues that truly
could not be overcome and
i think boston is the best team in the
nba
i think they will win it if they can
stay healthy
uh i think they're that good
defensively and roster construction wise
um
and so i think they got a horrible first
round opponent uh as well so everything
that could go wrong so far for the nets
has gone wrong
what's the coolest thing in your office
um let me look here
um
my mount kilimanjaro picture dan i i
climbed mount kilimanjaro
about eight years ago
and when i say i whimpered to the finish
line uh
i basically had to be dragged to the
finish line because we made a midnight
walk uh up what was the last day on like
two hours sleep and uh the guys who were
our guides
they basically told the friend i did it
with you got to go up and see your guy
he's having a mental breakdown because
at like
4 00 a.m in the cold of mount
kilimanjaro i was ready to break
did you cry
i didn't but literally if it had been
five more steps i might have
and then
the climb down was actually harder than
the climb up and they were just dragging
me down i mean they were just like this
dude is weak-minded and i was so
you know that i made it i all the way to
the top just you know i i worked for
this guy dan like long ago named gordon
chiese he was a long time assistant with
the utah jazz but i worked with him at
providence college and he used to always
tell players
despite yourself you're going to be
great like because and that was me on
that climb despite myself i made it to
the top i never understood why we don't
celebrate the sherpas more you know sir
edmund hillary i don't give a damn about
you it's the sherpa who is carrying all
your gear
listen i could have paid i think it was
like a hundred more bucks for them not
so i didn't have to carry the 50 pound
backpack that i was carrying i'm like
i waste money all the time i didn't
spend it on that all right because i was
trying to be tough that was stupid but
what used to kill me is we would get up
in the morning i think we're flying up
on this hike
and
these dudes are breaking down the camp
and they're like sprinting by us and
they're they finished the next day's
camp they had to be there two hours
early they're cooking i'm like how do
they do these people are super human
well uh congratulations on not crying
a bit i don't want to say this because
my friend is probably if he listens to
you every day he's he's out there
listening chris loman he's saying yeah
but
he almost did i almost had him
yeah
barely
you are a warrior hashtag warrior
weak minded thank you jeff safe travels
and uh we appreciate your time
all right take care dan that's jeff ann
gundy of the mothership